Guten Morgen, Andre.
Guten Morgen Linus.
Musik. Ja, wir sind hier nicht bei den Profis.
Eigentlich wollte ich mal sagen guten Abend Linus weiß es ja nie morgen bei dem Podcast.
Das darfst du nicht sagen.
Ich weiß, deswegen schneidest du das hier.
Welche äh welche Folge sind wir?
Das ist dein Podcast, keine Ahnung, eins vier, irgendwas.
Einhundert äh siebenundvierzig Logbuch Netzpolitik einhundert.
Siebenundvierzig. Wie ihr schon gemerkt habt, ist der liebe Tim heute nicht bei uns. Der ist äh woanders
wir sind auch nicht wirklich zusammen, wir haben ja ein sehr abenteuerliches Konstrukt aus verschiedenen USB-Geräten
Kopfhörern, Lautsprechern, Mikrofonen und Betriebssystemen gebaut, um euch in dieser Folge einen kleinen eine kleinen.
Rückblick, würde ich sagen, auf das Schaffen von Andre, insbesondere zu bieten.
Weil mich persönlich irgendwie immer so, wie ihr auch in den letzten Folgen gehört habt, so interessiert, wie ist das denn im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss? Ich war persönlich selber noch nie dort,
Ja, ich habe dieses, diese großzügig der Öffentlichkeit dort geboten, der Öffentlichkeit noch nicht wahrgenommen, sondern,
immer versucht, die schönen Protokolle zu lesen, die auf Netzpolitik org hauptsächlich von Andre geschrieben werden, aber jetzt als,
in der vergangenen Woche oder in der letzten Sitzung dann äh Prophalla da war, war ich ja eigentlich auch ganz froh, dass ich persönlich nicht vor Ort war.
Um diesem Schauspiel beizuwohnen, aber wir wollen uns das natürlich nicht nehmen lassen, da jetzt auch mal von Andre nochmal was von zu hören. Deswegen machen wir heute so einen kleinen Semesterrückblick über den.
Ersten parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss der achtzehnten Legislaturperiode des Deutschen Bundestages. War das richtig.
Eher nicht schlecht, dass du auswendig gelernt.
Du hast mir das ja gerade nochmal gesagt.
Ähm und vorher müssen wir uns aber noch damit auseinandersetzen, dass,
wie wir, wie ich ja in der letzten Sendung schon so ein bisschen gespoilert habe, der Generalbundesanwalt ja leider auf die Strafanzeige.
Das Chaos, Computerclubs, der Liga für die der internationalen Liga für Menschenrechte und des Vereines Digitalcourage eher nicht ermitteln möchte
hauptsächlich, weil sich ja gar nicht nachweisen lässt, dass das Merkel-Handy abgehört wurde, worauf sich unsere Strafanzeige eigentlich überhaupt nicht bezogen hat
gleichzeitig bezieht er sich darauf, dass er ja jetzt mit BND, BND und Verfassungsschutz und BSI gesprochen hat, Klammer auf BND und Verfassungsschutz waren mit
Zielpersonen unserer Anzeige, gegen die sich diese Strafanzeige gerichtet hat. Da möchte der Generalbundesanwalt also nicht ermitteln
Aber das Deutschlandradio verkündete ähm mehr oder weniger das offenbar gegen euch ermittelt wird, Andre.
Ja. Das stand da drin. Hat uns auch ein bisschen.
Im Deutschlandfunk, also in diesem Internet, in Deutschland Funk war es zu hören, äh Samstag vor anderthalb Wochen.
Wir haben ja heute Mittwoch, den fünfzehnten Juli.
'ne Meldung und 'n Kommentar von einem mir vorher unbekannten Journalisten, Rolf irgendwas, hab den Namen schon wieder vergessen.
Der Verfassungsschutzpräsident Maaßen, also.
So angepisst ist von diesen ganzen Leaks über Geheimdienste und das nicht mehr länger mit sich machen lassen will und da jetzt endlich mal was dagegen tut und Strafanzeige gestellt hat, ähm gegen die Details.
Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz an Medien gegeben haben und zwar einmal den sogenannten Korellibericht zum V-Mann Korelli, äh der dreihunderttausend Euro über zehn Jahre vom Bundesamt bekommen hat und vor kurzem,
mysteriös, tot aufgefunden ist, an bisher nicht diagnostizierten.
Was war das Zuckererkrankung? Diabetes? Äh das ist außerdem die süddeutsche zitiert hat, da wird geprüft.
Und zwei weitere Strafanzeigen betreffen, wie das beim Deutschlandfunk so schön hieß, einen Internetdienst.
Details zur Internetüberwachung vom Bundesverfassungsschutz veröffentlicht hat.
Und als Markus das gelesen hat, hat er mich erstmal angerufen und hat gemeint, ey, sind wir das vielleicht? Und dann haben wir die Artikel rausgesucht ausm Februar und April diesen Jahres. Und tatsächlich, es waren wir.
Wir hatten im Februar und im April äh Details mit internen ja internen Aufstellungen und Beschreibungen vom Verfassungsschutz,
wie der Verfassungsschutz denn in die Internet Überwachung jetzt nicht einsteigen. Es hat ja schon eine Weile gemacht, aber wie er sich da komplett neu aufstellen will, eine komplett neue Referatsgruppe gründen will und die Internetüberwachung einmal.
Technisch und organisatorisch äh komplett erneuern möchte, viel mehr Befugnisse möchte, mehr Ressourcen, äh neue Technik und vor allem, was den Verfassungsschutz umtreibt, Massendaten im Internet zu Überwachung und auszuwerten.
Hatten wir.
Ja berichtet, publiziert und dann natürlich wie ist so unser Stil ist, wenn wir original Dokumente haben und uns Quellen erlauben, das zu veröffentlichen, haben wir natürlich auch die Originalquellen mit veröffentlicht.
Fand der Verfassungsschutzpräsident jetzt nicht so super. Also das das war uns vorher klar, aber dass er dann tatsächlich.
Diesem Mittel greift Strafanzeige zu stellen, hätten wir nicht ganz erwartet. Ähm vielleicht erinnert sich,
ein oder andere, wir hatten das ja letzten Herbst schon mal als Kanzleramtschef Altmaier auch
War über Berichte, die immer übern BND und äh Kanzleramt und NSA
veröffentlicht werden. Da gab's ja schon mal einen Brief von äh Altmaier, in dem der vier Medienberichte aufgelistet hat, einmal Spiegel, einmal Süddeutsche, zweimal uns
ihm nicht gefällt und wenn das so weitergeht, dass er Strafanzeige stellen wird, das hat er dann irgendwann auch vorbereitet, aber dann gab's eine Intervention von Merkel und Altmaier hat das zurückgezogen,
Maaßen hat sich davon nicht beeindrucken lassen, hat das jetzt durchgezogen, hat,
Anzeige gestellt und die also laut Auskunft des Deutschlandfunks ermittelt der Generalbundesanwalt gegen unsere Quellen in zwei Fällen wegen wie heißt das so schön ähm Staatsverrat, Geheimnisverrat oder so.
Ja
Okay. Staatsverrat äh weiß ich nicht, ob's das gibt. Ähm ist denn nicht eigentlich der Verfassungsschutz für die Spionageabwehr zuständig?
Ja, ist er. Äh der ist.
Und dem dem fällt nichts besseres ein, als Strafanzeige. Beim Generalbundesanwalt zu stellen gegen was vermutlich seine eigenen Mitarbeiter sind?
Also nicht Staatsverrat, sondern wegen des Verdachts, das Staatsgeheimnisse verraten worden sein. Äh so war die Formulierung.
Ja der Bundesamt für verfasst, das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz ist auch für die Abwehr von Spionage.
Tätigkeiten zuständig. Vor ein paar Wochen, statt vor zwei, drei Wochen gab's wieder den aktuellen VS-Bericht, der.
Bundesamt und viele Landesamter veröffentlichen ja jährlich einen Bericht über was sich so getan haben. Und dann steht da auch mal ein Absatz zu ja wir haben jetzt ein,
dreihundertsechzig Grad Blick eingeführt,
und gucken jetzt äh nicht nur gegen unsere klassischen Feinde wie China, Russland und Iran, sondern Anlass bezogen auch gegen unsere sogenannten Freunde wie die USA. Wir haben ja da auch mal die Aufbauten auf den Botschaften beobachtet.
Aber leider können wir irgendwie nichts wirklich nachweisen, vor allem nicht so gut, dass der Generalbundesanwalt dagegen irgendwie ermitteln könnte.
Und bei der Pressekonferenz hat Maaßen dann auch gesagt, ja, aber irgendwie,
auch so als User, wenn man jetzt äh Onlinedienste nutzt, die in den USA sind,
kann man ja natürlich nicht davon ausgehen, dass andere Geheimnisse darauf keinen Zugriff haben, also in etwa von zu einem Abwehr von Spionage zuständig, aber wir sind alle selbst schuld, wenn wir Facebook nutzen, was wir alle tun, also ich.
Oder Apple wie Logbuch Netzpolitik nutzt. Oh.
Ja, aber wir haben ja dafür ganz gutes Audio eigentlich immer. Das funktioniert in der Regel bei uns ganz gut so. Möchtest du noch einen.
Ähm okay und jetzt jetzt stelle ich mir natürlich die Frage, warum macht der das, ne? Also ich glaube ähm.
Das ist ja eigentlich nur ein Signal, ne. Also wird er jetzt wirklich wird er da wirklich jemanden.
Also, ich meine, es könnte sogar sein, ja, vielleicht stellen sie sogar äh vielleicht stellen sie sogar fest, wer es war. Ich habe jetzt einfach mal geraten, dass es
potenziell jemand im eigenen Hause ist. So, ich meine, oder eben ein, also
irgendjemand muss ja irgendwann mal irgendwo äh seine Finger an diese Dokumente bekommen haben und sie dann irgendjemand anderen gegeben haben,
Das heißt, vermutlich sind sie, waren sie nur für dieses Haus bestimmt oder für Teile der Regierung. Das kann natürlich auch sein, wer weiß, wem für wen solche Dokumente alles bestimmt sind. Ähm.
Wenn er es herausgefunden hätte, wer es war, dann hätte er ja in dieser Person ein Exempel bereits statuiert, aber ich glaube, ähm.
Was verfolgt ihr denn? Also ich persönlich sehe eigentlich dadrin nur äh ein ein Unfähigkeits,
Ein Geständnis, dass eine, dass so eine, so eine Bude sich selber nicht unter Kontrolle hat und ähm
eigentlich so eine Bankrotterklärung macht und sagt uns fällt auch nichts besseres ein, als äh eine Anzeige zu formulieren. Aber es geht sicherlich ja auch darum,
potentielle andere Quellen äh für.
Äh journalistische äh Organe äh einzuschüchtern und denen vor Augen zu führen, dass sie irgendwie mit bösen Konsequenzen rechnen müssen, oder?
Also zu unseren Quellen kann ich natürlich weder was sagen noch mich irgendwie an Mutmaßungen beteiligen.
Aber dass der Chef des Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz,
jetzt nicht gerade darüber ist, dass wir nicht nur die komplette Selbstbeschreibung der einer neuen Einheit mit sechs Referaten,
und äh dem Stellenplan dazu ins Internet gestellt haben. Äh das war uns schon vorher klar, dass ähm muss er aber auch nicht. Das ist sicherlich seine Rolle in der Demokratie.
Er hat seinen Job zu machen und der umfasst nicht die das Jagen nach journalistischen Quellen.
Wir betrachten das auch ganz klar als Angriff auf die Pressefreiheit.
Ob der jetzt jemand findet oder nicht, also wir hoffen es natürlich nicht, weil es äh ja auch um unsere Quelle oder Quellen geht. Ähm.
Aber es es steht ein bisschen die Vermutung im Raum und das hat auch der Deutschlandfunk-Journalist, der die ursprüngliche Story gemacht hat in einem ja ziemlich.
Komischen, skurrilen Kommentar, den ihr vielleicht verlinken könnt, der so geschrieben, dass es weniger darum geht, jetzt äh diese Person, Personen, wer auch immer, wo unsere Quellen.
Zu finden, sondern eher einen Signal in die Zukunft zu senden, dass eben sich ein Geheimdienst wie der Verfassungsschutz es sich nicht gefallen lassen kann, wenn seine interne, wie er denn jetzt äh überwacht an die Öffentlichkeit kommen,
deswegen mal ein Zeichen setzen möchte, dass er sich das nicht gefallen lässt und dass jetzt andere Seiten aufgezogen werden.
Es gerüchtet so ein bisschen im politischen Berlin,
dass äh natürlich auch der Verfassungsschutz jetzt aufmerksam beobachtet hat, wie das im Geheimdienst Untersuchungsausschuss vor sich ging und was da alles über den BND bekannt wurde und wie der BND-Präsident das vielleicht auch nicht immer alles gut fand, was da so in der Zeitung,
und anderen Medien stand, aber wie der sich das äh halbwegs über sich ergehen lassen hat. Ähm.
Ist ja absehbar, dass auch das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz noch in dem Ausschuss behandelt wird und manche sehen das auch schon als Zeichen äh an den Ausschuss oder Beteiligte und Journalisten und andere interne Quellen.
Es nicht zu bunt zu treiben und sich nicht zu sehr mit dem Verfassungsschutz anzulegen, weil er nicht alles mit sich machen lässt, wie der BND oder so.
Dass ja das Maßen angefressen war, das war uns vorher klar, aber das ist ja auch gerade die Rolle einer öffentlichen Diskussion in der, ja, in der Bevölkerung, die wir mit unserer Berichterstattung anstoßen wollen.
Was würdest du denn sagen? Also ich meine ähm die Frage stellt sich natürlich auch immer wieder, ne, dass äh.
Was ja dann bei gerade bei solchen Leaks, wenn sie so in diesem Ausmaß stattfinden, dass man sich die Frage stellt, okay, wem ist damit jetzt wirklich,
geholfen, ne? Also der ihr veröffentlicht jetzt ja hier das und das und das und das so und so viel Geld wollen die ausgeben für äh äh für folgende Dinge, die sie alle tun wollen. Das wollen sie sich anschaffen. Das ist natürlich für uns.
Ausgesprochen
interessant mal so abzulesen, so um deren äh Status zu sehen und deren Fähigkeiten uns zu überlegen, wie wir entsprechend als Gesellschaft dastehen bei diesen
Überwachungsmöglichkeiten. Andererseits wird ja immer wieder gesagt, OK, das schadet ja auch,
den Interessen des des deutschen Staates oder des deutschen Volkes für das der Verfassungsschutz ja sich die ganze Zeit einsetzt.
Wieso haut ihr das dann trotzdem vollständig raus?
Mal wieder eine schöne Frage. Ähm.
Wir haben da auch ein bisschen ähm natürlich von der Berichterstattung aus den Snowden League gelernt. Wir haben auch schon vorher immer Originaldokumente veröffentlicht, wenn wir sie hatten und unsere Quellen das gut fanden. Aber vorher gab's einfach nicht so viele original Dokumente,
zu Überwachungsthemen und ich finde die Berichterstattung zu Snowden hat da schon ein bisschen ein Standard gesetzt.
Wo selbst der Spiegel der jetzt nicht gerade gerne links auf andere setzt oder gar Dokumente veröffentlicht.
Wie Darlehen und die anderen beteiligten Medien dann später auch natürlich die Intercept die vor zwei Wochen irgendwie vierzig X Kiescore, PDFs veröffentlicht haben.
Das vorgelebt haben. Wir haben die Originaldokumente, die gehören nicht uns.
Die wurden mit Steuergeldern finanziert und wenn sie im öffentlichen Interesse sind,
dann sollten die auch in die Öffentlichkeit. Ich mein, ich hab das Zeug auch noch studiert, aber normalerweise lernt man in jeder Schule über unsere Demokratie,
im amerikanischen gibt's da den schönen Spruch, dass Demokratie, die informierte Zustimmung der des Souveränens der Bevölkerung ist,
Wenn ich noch nicht mal informiert darüber bin, dann kann ich ja erst recht nicht zustimmen. Aber für eine gesellschaftliche Debatte,
ist ja im Internet sowieso noch klarer als in anderen Medien, dass man da möglichst nah an der Originalquelle,
sich informiert und das ist eben nicht nur der original Spiegel oder süddeutsche Bericht, sondern eben auch das original Dokument,
bei uns aufm Server ist genug Platz dafür. Es gibt keinen Grund, warum wir nicht Originaldokumente veröffentlichen sollten. Und das tun wir auch weiterhin und auch wenn man versucht uns einzuschüchtern mit jetzt den,
schärfsten Geschütze, was irgendwie die bundesdeutsche Justiz so hat.
Sehr schön. Ähm.
Gleichzeitig finde ich ja immer sehr interessant. Also jetzt wär's mal, jetzt wär's echt mal schön zu sehen, ähm.
Ich erinnere mich an diesen an, ich glaube, das war der der erste.
Große Vortrag auf dem sechsundzwanzig C drei. Wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche oder fünfundzwanzig, sechsundzwanzig C drei glaube ich oder? Daniel,
Berg und äh Julio A Sanchez, die äh erwähnten oder wo dann drin gesagt wurde, dass sie im Prinzip vom
BKA war das, glaube ich, so eine so eine Mail bekommen haben, äh nehmt unsere Materialien von eurer Webseite, ne
wodurch quasi bestätigt war, dass die echt sind. Bei dem, bei eurem bei eurer Berichterstattung
inklusive Originalquelle über diese äh Planungen des äh Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz gab's da jemals irgendwie Zweifel, ob diese Materialien echt sind?
Wenn ich mich recht erinnere, war das damals die Sache, dass Wikileaks ein paar IP-Ranges und Netze des BND oder Tarnfilmen veröffentlicht hat,
Der BND hat dann ein Wickeligs geschrieben, nehmt das mal runter, äh was dann so die Bestätigung war, dass das echt ist. Äh und dann wurden die auch ziemlich schnell geändert die Netze.
Ich hab natürlich oder bei den Sachen wo ich meine Finger mit drinne hatte, hatte ich wenig Zweifel ob die Dokumente echt sind, weil ich das ja auch selber verifizieren konnte.
Unsere Leserinnen und Leser sollen natürlich ohne jetzt mit den Stichwort der Medienkompetenz zu kommen immer selber einschätzen ob sie das für plausibel halten und echt halten,
Tatsächlich hat ja der äh Verfassungsschutzpräsident mit dieser Strafanzeige.
Mittlerweile auch zu halt bestätigt ist, ähm die Echtheit verifiziert, dafür danken wir sehr, aber wir haben natürlich,
in guter journalistischer Tradition und Handwerk vor der Veröffentlichung dieser beiden Berichte des Bundesamt jeweils davor um Stellungnahme gebeten. Wir haben gesagt, wir haben,
die so das erfahren und haben dazu folgende Fragen möchtet ihr uns nicht bitte paar Fragen beantworten und Kommentar dazu abgeben,
normalerweise sagen die dann gerne mal so 'n oder so 'n ausschweifendes, wir halten uns an alle rechten des Gesetzes und unsere Verpflichtungen.
Aber in den Fällen hatten die gar nicht auf wiederholte Anfrage, also nicht mal ein Nein äh geantwortet,
wir ziemlich komisch fanden. Aber durch die Strafanzeige ist das ja jetzt auch eine Bestätigung, dass die Dokumente echt sind. Vielen Dank dafür.
Ich find's jetzt witzig, ob der äh Range jetzt überhaupt davon ausgehen kann, dass die echt sind, ne? Weil.
Prüft das jetzt wahrscheinlich.
Der prüft jetzt, ob die echt sind und dann wird der rausfinden, dass er das nicht, dass er das nicht rausfinden kann, weil dafür müsste ihm ja der Maaßen sagen, dass die echt sind. Also.
Ja, na, das wird, das hat der bestimmt schon gemacht. Wir haben natürlich die Strafanzeige nicht, aber im Gegensatz zu amerikanischen Behörden sind deutsche Behörden zur Mitarbeit verpflichtet beim Generalbundesanwalt und der Maaßen hat ja auch ein ureigenes Interesse daran.
Äh ich ich weiß schon, ich denke halt so, es ist halt sehr witzig. Ich meine, wir haben sackweise Snowden-Dokumente
und in dieser äh ranischen Ablehnung der Ermittlungen in im
in in in Reaktion auf die Strafanzeige steht halt immer so drin, ja, das kann ja alles nicht das ist ja alles nicht original, das ist ja alles nicht echt und im im Spiegel war ja auch nur die Abschrift einer Selektorenliste, das sind ja den,
fehlt ja die Beweiskraft ähm
Finde ich schon ganz interessant, wie wie schnell er da switchen kann zwischen was ein ein echtes Dokument ist und was nicht. Weil das äh Edwards mit
mit Maaßen hat er einen Zeugen, der sagt, dieses Dokument ist echt hier vom Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und mit Edward Snowden hat er auch einen Zeugen, den er ja aber gar nicht äh mit dem er gar nicht sprechen möchte, ne? Das hat er auch gesagt, also SNON macht ja nicht den Eindruck, was zu wissen
Deswegen braucht er den nicht weiter zu fragen.
Ja, ich glaube, Ranger hatte tatsächlich mal eine E-Mail an Snowden geschickt, so kannst du nicht uns auch mal die original Dokumente geben.
Damit wir das verifizieren können, aber hat 'ne ablehnende oder ich weiß nicht ob überhaupt.
Aber tatsächlich ist es für eine deutsche Behörde ungleich schwerer äh an Originaldokumente von ausländischen und vor allem Geheimdiensten zu kommen, als von einem inländisch, von der inländischen Behörde, die dazu auch noch umfassend,
kooperiert mit der Behörde den Punkt sehe ich schon, ich seh's trotzdem ein Skandal es ganz gerade der Generalbundesanwalt ist den Justizministerium unterstellt und da passieren öfters mal politische Entscheidungen.
Auch wenn's um Asyl anderer politisch Verfolgter geht, wenn's da irgendwie von ganz oben ein Go gibt, dann geht plötzlich alles ganz schnell.
Ähm und in der Frage der Überwachung der ja kompletten Bevölkerung oder zumindest massenhaften Bevölker Überwachung große Teile der Bevölkerung oder sogar diese einen komischen Person im Kanzleramt.
War halt die politische Ansage eher zu sagen, mach mal langsam, jetzt übertreib's mal nicht hier. Umso krasser, dass jetzt eben,
an nicht nur an den Grundfreiheiten von ja der Ausprägung der Menschenwürde in Punkto Datenschutz, sondern eben auch in der Grundfreiheit der Pressefreiheit,
gerüttelt wird, wenn eben in das grundgesetzlich.
Geschützte Verhältnis zwischen Journalisten und ihren Informanten eingegriffen wird, wie es im Cicero-Urteil zweitausendsieben nochmal bestätigt wurde, sondern dass man jetzt hier gleich mit voller Gewalt äh auf.
Mutmaßliche Quellen und potenzielle Nachahmer Whistle Blower schießt. Das finde ich äh den viel größeren Skandal, als ob er jetzt das Dokument verifiziert hat oder nicht.
Und du sagst also, er sollte sich, sie sollte das quasi als äh die Niederlage äh mit mit Fassung tragen.
Schindler war letzte Woche auf der Netzwerkrecherche, Jahrestagung und hat gemeint, ja wenn sie mal wieder ein geheimes Dokument veröffentlichen, dann ist das halt doof für mich,
Aber dann ist das halt so, weil Pressefreiheit, aber der Maaßen sieht das nicht ganz so. Irgendwie ticken die Uhren in Köln da ein bisschen anders als im Pullach,
der Verfassungsschutz, der ist irgendwie total angefressen,
und äh zwar so sehr, dass er jetzt mit einem der größten Geschütze der, ja, bundesdeutschen Justiz,
auf uns und unsere Quellen schießt das für dich schon ganz schön krass und vor allem der wird das nicht gemacht haben ohne Rückendeckung mit dem Innenministerium.
Damals als Altmeier Kanzleramt Strafanzeige stellen wollte hat Merkel gesagt, nee ist nicht, aber jetzt,
eben Maßen Strafanzeige gestellt und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das Innenministerium oder sogar der Innenminister davon, dass nicht zumindest akzeptiert haben.
Das finde ich schon ganz schön krass, weil das geht wirklich an die Grund.
An die Grund äh Prinzipien der Pressefreiheit und Deutschland schimpft sich äh in der Rangliste der Pressefreiheit auf Platz zwölf, aber ob das mit solchen Methoden lange haltbar ist, das ist echt fraglich, denn irgendwie,
spätestens seit äh dem Zitzerofall zwotausendfünf, aber wahrscheinlich auch noch viele Jahre vorher, hat der Generalbundesanwalt,
nicht mehr gegen journalistische Quellen ermittelt, sondern nur noch äh kleinere Stellen.
Könntest du den den Cicero-Fall, weil du den jetzt mehrmals referenziert hast, äh kurz im, in Grundzügen umreißen, worum's da genau ging?
Auch nur ganz ganz grobe. Ich glaube, das war zwotausendfünf.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr um welches Thema es ging, ich glaube irgendein Kriegseinsatz, das müsste ich jetzt aber auch nochmal nachlesen, dass es eventuell um.
Ich will nicht zu sehr äh Halbwissen verbreiten, jedenfalls wurden damals Redaktionsräume des Magazins Cicero und glaube ich auch die.
Wohnungen des Dominik betroffenen Journalisten durchsucht. Äh und das war dann ein lang, um Quellen zu finden,
Ähm das war dann ein langjähriger Rechtsstreit und im Endeffekt hat äh der Journalist und äh das Medium nach langem Rest,
ziemlich deutlich gewonnen mit einem Grundsatz Pressefreiheitsurteil vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, wo eben drinsteht, äh Durchsuchungen,
gegen äh Redaktionsräume und Privaträume äh von Journalisten auf der Suche nach äh Informanten sind eigentlich gar nicht äh und wenn dann nur unter extrem engen Bedingungen,
notwendig äh zu es ist elementarer Teil äh Bestandteil der Pressefreiheit,
Journalisten mit Informanten treffen und auch dieses faire, wo Journalisten und potentielle Informanten miteinander kommunizieren, ist ein Bereich, in dem der Staat eigentlich keinen Zugriff haben sollte.
Weil sonst ist Essig mit Pressefreiheit, wenn äh jeder potenzielle Besuch mit äh Informanten äh sofort überwacht werden könnte, dann gibt's keine investigativen Journalismus nur, sondern nur noch irgendwie
Wie nennt man das Zitronismus? Das ist nur noch irgendwie abgeschrieben wird, was auf irgendwelchen Pressestatements verlautbart wird oder so. Das kann man ja aber nicht als Journalismus bezeichnen.
Ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund, also zumindest inzwischen befinden sich die der Redaktionsraum von Netzpolitik Org ja woanders, aber äh wir hatten auch, glaube ich, äh als ich noch dort war, Netzwerk Org äh Redaktionsraum an der Tür stehen.
Immer noch hier auf der wir sind nur im selben Office im Büro weitergezogen.
Genau, ich weiß, aber ich war, ist immerhin eine andere Tür. Ich weiß nicht, ob das Schild ich weiß nicht, ob das Schild mit umgezogen ist.
Das finden die nie.
Ja, jetzt wollte ich hier so ein bisschen Unklarheit.
Ist das Schild noch da? Nee, ne?
Wir haben ein Netzpolitik, wir da steht jetzt glaube ich nicht Redaktions kaum drauf, sondern unser Logo und ein großes Poster von unserem Buch überwachtes Netz zum äh ja den Snowdenenthündungen.
Wenn man auch nach uns fragt, findet man uns auch, wir sind äh aus in der Etage und im Gebäude ausgeschildert, die Adresse steht auf der Webseite.
Und wenn man im Büro uns finden möchte, dann tut man das auch. Und ich glaube, wenn man die Generalbundesanwaltschaft ist, dann ist man auch in der Lage, in unserem Büro, ähm unseren Redaktionsraum zu.
Man merkt so richtig, wie du gerne hättest, dass die jetzt kommen, ne.
Nee, um Gottes Willen. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Also wir sind natürlich vorbereitet, aber das waren wir ja schon immer. Ähm gerade in ich mein.
Haben jetzt noch nie irgendwie Gefälligkeitsjournalismus gemacht, aber grade irgendwie im letzten Jahr haben wir ja durchaus irgendwie,
BND und Bundeskanzleramt und BSI und Berliner Polizei und so jetzt nicht gerade sanft behandelt und von jedem mal was gelingt.
Also dass wir irgendwie eventuell nicht die allerbesten Freunde sind, selbst wenn wir irgendwelche Preise kriegen,
sondern die eine oder andere Person uns durch mal durchaus mal ein bisschen näher äh betrachten würde, davon gehen wir schon aus,
aber und wir sind auch auf sowas vorbereitet. Wir treffen natürlich alle möglichen Maßnahmen, die man so treffen kann, äh gutes Gewissens,
aber dass man sich jetzt wünschen würde, dass sie über eines einreiten, um Gottes Willen, erstens wären wir da uns mit unserer Arbeit lahmgelegt, zweitens ähm kommen wir dann nicht mehr zu unserer eigenen eigentlichen Arbeit, wir wollen ja Inhalte,
veröffentlichen und verbreiten sondern müssen uns dann erstmal mit so 'nem Meta-Thema irgendwie Angriff auf uns beschäftigen.
Und drittens, das wär auch 'n Scheißsignal für andere Medien, wenn jetzt tatsächlich sich der Staat die.
Frechheit rausnehmen würde in den Redaktionsraum einzureiten, weil das haben sie seit Cicero eben nicht mehr so einfach gemacht und das ist auch gut so.
Falls die das tun würden, dann wäre das nicht nur ein Angriff auf uns, sondern auch auf alle anderen Redaktionen, die mit äh Informanten,
arbeiten, was fast alle Investigativen Journalisten tun.
Okay, dann kommen wir doch mal zu meinem zu meinem anderen Thema, was über das ich nochmal so gerne mit dir sprechen wollte. Der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Wie hältst du das aus.
Ja, also ohne Hammer, ohne mir auf den Finger zu hauen, ähm sondern eigentlich viel Koffein, auch wenn die Matte im Bundestag zwei Euro kostet.
Die haben da Mate, die verkaufen echt Mate jetzt.
Ja, denn man muss zwar seine Glasflasche am Eingang eingeben, aber man kann dann reingehen und sich drinnen eine Matteflasche in einer Glasflasche kaufen. Äh aber es ist jetzt auch nicht ganz neu, dass äh das gibt's schon seit eins, zwei, drei Jahren oder so.
Ich weiß, dass Markus immer in der in der Enquete-Kommission, ne. Da musste er dann irgendwann glücklicherweise bei den Hausausweis hat, äh hatte dann nicht mehr, wurde er nicht mehr so kontrolliert. Und dann konnte er halt Mate schmuggeln
und er war so eine der wenigen, also er war halt in der Lage in den Bundestag mit Martha reinzugehen und meine wurde mir immer weggenommen an der Tür, deswegen musste er dann für mich Mathe schmuggeln. Und jetzt, jetzt dealen die echt mit Mate. Das ist krass.
Gemacht, ja.
Das ist im Prinzip könnte man sagen, das ist ja gut leben in Deutschland eigentlich.
Bis auf, dass die zwei Euro kostet. Das Essen ist da drin, aber die Matte ist äh teurer als im Prenzlauer Bergspeti.
Okay.
Wie ich das aushalte, also es kommt ja total auf die Sitzung an. Die sind ja alle vollkommen unterschiedlich. Äh manchmal,
ähm sitzt man eigentlich mehr draußen und ist unterbrochen durch namentliche Abstimmungen, wo man auch mal ganz entspannt runter in die Kantine zum Mittagessen gehen kann,
es kommt aber auch manchmal vor, dass man irgendwie zwölf Stunden da sitzt und zwischendurch nur zweimal, fünf Minuten Pause hat, wenn überhaupt. Manchmal.
Zum Essen oder Trinken, einfach nur, weil ich sonst wieder zwei Sätze äh verpassen würde zum Niederschreiben und irgendwie.
Pofalla hat 'ne Stunde lang ein Eingangstatement gehalten, von dem ich natürlich so viel wie möglich aufschreiben wollte, weil das
am Stück ging, auch wenn er sehr repetativ war
Aber im Gegensatz zu dem Frage- und Antwortspiel danach äh war da weniger Pause, äh wo man auch mal kurz irgendwie mal einen Schluck trinken konnte und da muss man schon in einer Stunde lang ganz schön durchrattern. Ansonsten
ähm.
Ja äh einfach Augen zu und am nächsten Tag mal ein bisschen länger schlafen äh ist zwar körperlich nicht gerade angenehm
aber irgendjemand muss ja, weil gibt ja leider keinen Livestream oder offizielle Protokolle und wenn die irgendwann mal veröffentlicht werden, dann interessiert's niemand mehr, dann liest das ja niemand mehr.
Wie ist das denn? Ich meine, wenn Pofalla eine Stunde redet und man sich in die Rolle des begeben hat, der da einfach nur protokolliert, ja? Ähm.
Der wird, wenn der Pofalla eine Stunde redet, wie viel Unwahrheit oder wie viel ähm was heißt Unwahrheit, wie viel Kreative Auslegung der Geschehnisse ist denn dabei?
Also,
eine der Bedingungen, die öffentliche Besucher ja machen müssen auf der Besuchertribüne, ist äh keine Beifalls oder Unmutsbekundungen abgeben.
Das fällt manchmal schon echt schwer.
Ich mein, je näher man den politischen Betrieb kommt, ähm,
durchaus äh auch Argumente hin und her, die halt nicht ganz so einfach sind, wie es eine einfache Schlagzeile manchmal vermuten lässt. Und
Weltbild und aus den Informationen, die er damals hatte.
Also er bleibt natürlich total arroganter Typ, der meint, dass er nie Fehler gemacht hat und einmal einen Halbsatz anders gesagt hätte, aber in seiner Weltsicht,
hat er wirklich keine Fehler gemacht und wenn man ihn mal kohärent für eine Stunde zuhört dann dann,
Ist das irgendwo auch in sich geschlossenes Bild, was Mensch, was man meint, dass man Menschen zugestehen kann, dass man das vertreten kann, dass man das dann anders sieht.
Das ist im politischen Betrieb immer so aber auch wenn's wehtut,
zuzuhören. Es ist gar nicht so schwer, das dann einfach runterzuschreiben
weil die anderen Abgeordneten, die kontern das ja auch mit ihren Fragen und nach dem Eingangsstatement, wo die Zeugen ja immer loswerden wollen, was sie so denken
den Ausschuss interessieren könnte und äh wenn sie dann ein eigenes Statement abgeben, sich mal ein bisschen reinwaschen wollen, kommen die eigentlich interessanteren Sachen, ja dann erst danach
vor allem die Opposition aber eigentlich aller Abgeordneten dann anfangen ihre kritischen Fragen zu stellen und hm Antworten erzwingen wollen, die die Leute eben nicht gleich im Eingang Statement schon mit beantworten wollten.
Und hattest du den Eindruck, dass es den Profiler dann da in dieser Befragung dann auch wirklich mal äh ans Leder ging, also wurde er da mal gegrillt oder hat der na, hat der sich auch da dann gut verteidigen können? Also man würde ja von einem Menschen, der äh kann's Kanzleramtschef
und irgendwie Bahnlobby ist, ist, äh, eigentlich vermuten, dass es, dass es unmöglich ist, den aus seiner Argumentationslinie zu holen.
Das kommt so ein bisschen drauf an. Jetzt fange ich auch schon an Juristen und Politiker antworten zu geben,
ähm an der ein oder anderen Stelle ähm gab's schon mal eine ziemlich krasse Auseinandersetzung mit ihm. Also,
war eins der unterhaltsamsten äh eine der Unterhaltsameren Sitzungen. Da kam's dann richtig zu äh teilweise ja.
Haben die, haben sich dann die Abgeordneten und Pofalla angemacht gegenseitig, von wegen, komm erstmal in mein Auto, da sage ich, du, erstmal zwanzig Jahre Jurist, ich habe ja viel mehr Erfahrung als du, ich war schon mal Minister, du bist nur Abgeordneter.
Und so, das war schon ganz schön krass zu hören, wie die wirklich auf so 'ner persönlichen Ebene hantiert haben und einmal hat er auch gemeint, die gibt ja die sogenannte,
Berliner Stunde im Ausschuss, dass die Fraktionen nur so viel Fragezeit haben, relativ wie eben ihre Mehrheitsverhältnisse im Bundestag und auch im Ausschuss sind,
Das heißt, die Union kann immer so, was weiß ich, äh mehrere zwanzig, fast eine halbe Stunde Fragen stellen,
um die äh Oppositionsparteien kommen dann immer so auf sechs oder acht Minuten.
Und die haben's quasi ziemlich schwer dran zu kommen oder immer erst eine Stunde später wieder und einmal hat dann gemeint, wenn sie mich jetzt nicht ausreden lassen, dann laber ich hier einfach so lange, bis ihre Zeit vorbei ist, dass sie in den acht Minuten keine weitere Frage stellen können.
Boah.
Dreist fande ich.
Der hat den Begriff labern benutzt.
Ne, das.
Weiß ich nicht mehr so ganz genau, es steht um Protokoll ist ja jetzt auch schon wieder zwei Wochen her, aber so ungefähr äh kam's rüber, ja, dann rede ich hier so lang, äh bis ihre Zeit vorbei ist.
Teilweise kommt's dann auch so zu nein, doch, nein, doch, äh, zwischen Abgeordneten und Zeugen hin und her.
Aber ich glaube jetzt kaum, das ist ja, du warst ja selber schon öfters mal im Bundestag, ich glaube kaum, dass,
viele Bühnen, vor allem öffentliche Bühnen in Parlamenten dazu beitragen
dass man sich wirklich alle Argumente anhört und dann seine Meinung ändert. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass irgendwie die Opposition eine andere Meinung gehabt hätte nach der Sitzung oder dass ich eine andere Meinung gehabt hätte oder dass Pofalla eine andere Gemeinung,
gehabt hätte.
Insofern geht auch er mit dem Gefühl raus jetzt endlich mal alles losgeworden zu sein und wenn er sich kein groben Fehler erlaubt hat dann kann er auch sagen ja das war's ja jetzt. Ich bin ja jetzt schon wieder reingewaschen.
Äh das finde ich äh finde ich ein sehr ein sehr wichtigen Aspekt. Ich meine, wenn in einem,
Wenn in einer Bundestagsdebatte irgendwie ein Gesetzesentwurf verdebattiert wird, der irgendwie seit sechs Monaten oder was in den Mühlen der der
Kirmes dort ist, äh dann ist klar, da werden keine Meinungen mehr äh äh
transportiert. Da geht's allenfalls eventuell darum, äh mit einem mit einem markanten Zitat irgendwie die in die Tagesschaukamera reinzublicken.
Wenn so ein äh so eine Sachverständigenanhörung ist wie ähm wie ich sie da ab und zu mal äh besucht habe, dann äh
passiert da auch immer sehr wenig, aber zumindest hast du den Eindruck, dass ihr irgendwie dann versuchen, so die wichtigsten.
Einwände oder Ergänzungen.
Der äh der Sachverständigen in irgend so einer Art von Form noch zu berücksichtigen, ne? Aber bei einem Untersuchungsausschuss gehe ich ja dann doch davon aus,
dass der ja am Ende, der muss sich ja tatsächlich eine Meinung bilden, also der Auftrag eines Untersuchungsausschusses ist ja unter Suche
und mache Abschlussbericht. Und ich habe da mich letztens mit der Anne Roth äh mal ein bisschen drüber unterhalten, weil das ja ganz interessant sein wird, wie jetzt die
Koalition und Opposition in diesen Mehrheitsverhältnissen, die ja sowieso absolut absurd sind, äh im Moment vor allem für die Untersuchung eines ähm.
Eines Umstandes, an dem die an dem die Regierung in diesem Ausmaß beteiligt ist. Ähm,
die müssen ja trotzdem am Ende einen gemeinsamen Bericht schreiben. Und wenn ich Anne richtig verstanden habe, ist das so.
Werden jetzt natürlich am Ende über diesen Bericht irgendwie äh Monate äh und über jede einzelnen Teilsatz dieses Berichts monatelang diskutieren.
Und am Ende.
Wird dieser Bericht aber halt so stehen, dass alle da ihre Meinung drin haben. Und oder das, was sie als Konsens haben können und
Schöne, was die Opposition machen kann, ist, sie kann eben ein, wie heißt das, Minderheitenvotum mit in den Bericht schreiben.
Wo sie dann sagen, so in dem Bericht steht zwar Folgendes, aber wir sehen das anders, ne?
Und das ist natürlich dann quasi, wenn die Opposition das zu oft macht, dann ähm.
Sieht man eben, dieser Untersuchungsausschuss ist einfach nicht zu seinem Ergebnis gekommen. Das heißt, die äh die Koalition, die diesen
Untersuchungsausschuss dominiert
hat da schon irgendwie noch ein Grund die Opposition da irgendwie mit auch zu befrieden, damit dieser Untersuchungsausschuss in seinem Ergebnis am Ende
auch überhaupt ernst genommen wird. Wenn da jetzt jemand reingeht und sagt, pass mal auf, ich labere dir jetzt hier äh ich laber dich jetzt gleich voll und dann geht dir deine Fragezeit weg, ne? Das finde ich ähm,
Das ist ja wirklich, also das ist ja wirklich absolut,
Also gibt's da nicht irgendeinen kann man das, kann man so, also ist ja völlig daneben. Da würde ich ja jetzt eigentlich erwarten, dass das so jemand
ganz schroff äh zur Ordnung gerufen wird oder haben da alle nur gelacht und haben gesagt, geile Sau hier
Also wie geht man damit um? Also da müsste man doch eigentlich kreideweis werden und sagen, das gibt's doch hier wohl nicht. Das ist ein Untersuchungsausschuss.
Also da ist jetzt irgendwie eine ganze Palette an Themen aufgemacht. Ähm,
nochmal das Erste. Ähm tatsächlich ist die Symbolpolitik für die Kamera und die Öffentlichkeit mehr im Plenum, äh gerade bei Gesetzesbeschlüssen, da ist ja schon Monate oder jahrelange Meinungsbildung intern passiert.
Und Macht und Durchsetzungspolitik und Kompromisse in den Ausschüssen wo du öfters mal sitzt,
da ist das auch eher für die Öffentlichkeit, damit man jede Meinung mal gesagt hat und eventuell überzeugt man ja noch den ein oder anderen und Untersuchungsausschüsse haben in der Tat nochmal ein bisschen den anderen Fokus,
ähm um eben Sachen herauszufinden, aber der Untersuchungsausschuss äh wie er funktioniert oder allgemein, aber dieser in besonderen, weil ich den am detailliertesten verfolge,
sind ja nicht nur die öffentlichen Sitzungen. Ein Großteil der Arbeit basiert ja auf den Akten. Die haben ja was weiß ich wie viele tausend, hunderttausend,
Akten, Seiten in was weiß ich wie vielen Dutzend oder sogar hunderten Akten ordnen,
und da passiert ein Großteil der eigentlichen Ausschussarbeit das zu lesen, das zu verstehen und dann daraus Fragen an die Zeugen zu generieren.
Und was wir in der Öffentlichkeit in der öffentlichen Sitzungen eben sehen, ist ja nun ein Bruchstück.
Der Arbeit. Das was dann eben mit Menschen gemacht wird mit mit Zeugen was dann.
Für Ex-Minister und gerade so eine Profis, natürlich dann wieder so eine politische Bühne ist, dem sie sich nicht komplett entziehen können, aber die sind dort auch unter Wahrheitspflicht und müssen dort auch äh wahrheitsmäßig aussagen.
Trotzdem also es kommt im Untersuchungsausschuss öfters mal zu überraschenden, neuen Erkenntnissen, wie zum Beispiel.
Ähm die Datenschutzbeauftragte des BND. Es gibt ja Zeugen, die kommen da hin und sagen, ich sage euch gar nichts.
Publiken Abgeordneten, hat mir gar nichts zu sagen, ich bin der Superagent James Bond äh und ich lebe in meiner Geheimdienstwelt und das bleibt so,
gibt andere, die haben einen gewissen und die wollen jetzt endlich mal ähm mit ihr ja mit der Wahrheit ans Licht und wollen jetzt auch mal so ein bisschen aussagen und die Datenschutzbeauftragte hat ja dann auch gesagt,
Ihre Rechtsverfassung ist, dass Sie sich damit gegen Haus nicht durchsetzen.
Und auch ein paar Details genannt, so die Datenbanken, Inbay und Veras,
und das Verbindungsdaten über fünf Ebenen gesprochen werden und so, das sind Erkenntnisse, da weiß ich gar nicht, ob die in den Akten stehen und die sind das erste Mal öffentlich so verlautbart und kommen dann bestimmt auch so in den Abschlussbericht und das ist ganz interessant,
aber nach dem BND-Zeugen sind wir jetzt bei Kanzleramtszeugen und vor allem je höher man jetzt kam von Unterteilungsleiter, Abteilungsleiter,
und jetzt eben zum ehemaligen Chef des Bundeskanzleramt war eine der höchsten Zeugen, die mir bisher da hatten. Es ist natürlich Profis, die diese Bühne schon jahrelang beherrschen,
und wenn die nicht 'nen, wenn die sich nicht total scheiße vorbereitet haben oder denen irgendeinen Patzer passiert wie teilweise.
Was war das bei Gabriel im zweiten Untersuchungsausschuss Emediati Untersuchungsausschuss, wo er irgendwie Oppermann dann in die Bredouille gebracht hat mit einer falschen Aussage oder so, weil er nicht gut genug vorbereitet.
Dann gehen die meisten schon da raus und sagen, so ich habe denen jetzt alles erzählt, was sie wissen wollten, ich bin mit mir im Reinen und ich habe keinen Fehler gemacht.
Allenfalls sind die anderen Schuld und wir könnten darüber nachdenken, das System zu verbessern.
Das ist ja auch so 'ne Eigenart, dass alle im Kanzleramt sagen, der BND ist schuld und alle BND sagen das Kanzleramt ist Schuld.
Jetzt habe ich so lange äh gelabert, dass ich den Rest deiner Frage vergessen hatte, zu den Minderheiten wurden das natürlich.
Ein anderer Aspekt, aber das ist natürlich erst am Ende der Ausschussarbeit bis der Abschlussbericht geschrieben wird, der dann wirklich nur der Konsens von allen ist und die Minderheiten wurden meistens das interessantere sind, das ist auch gar nicht so unüblich.
Ist es ja noch ein Stückchen, bis dahin hat der Ausschuss noch einige Themenfelder vor sich, die noch nicht mal begonnen haben.
Äh meine Frage war am Ende nur noch, äh wie wird da, also wenn da so ein Pofalla hingeht und sagte, ich labere dir deine Redezeit kaputt. Ja, was ist da, ist das etwas, was was da als Affront gesehen wird oder als als irgendwie coole Aktion?
Also da müssen wir den politischen Betrieb auch nochmal ein bisschen genauer betrachten. Wir haben ja die dreiundachtzig Prozent Große Koalition von Union und SPD im Bundestag.
In der Regierung aktuell, verantwortlich für das Kanzleramt,
und natürlich auch abgebildet in dem Ausschuss. Ähm auch in dem Ausschuss haben Union und SPD die dreiundachtzigprozentige Mehrheit,
Die haben ja dann mit ihrer äh großen Koalitionsmehrheit auch dann den Sonderermittler beschlossen und so ein Zeug und beschlossenes Noten nicht nach Deutschland einfliegen zu lassen gegen die Opposition.
Aber wir haben da trotzdem auch noch die Perspektive.
Abgeordneter in dem Parlament haben eigentlich ein freies Mandat und wollen sich auch nicht immer.
Kommt so ein bisschen drauf an, wie sehr man Parteisoldat ist, aber nicht immer was von der Regierung und der Exekutive äh quasi dem Anderen äh der anderen Institution in der Demokratie,
was vorschreiben lassen, auch wenn man teilweise in derselben Partei ist. Es gibt da solche und solche.
Aber durchaus haben wir auch in der letzten Sitzung, wo äh Güte heiß da war, ehemaliger ähm oder immer noch sogar,
Abteilungsleiter sechs im Bundeskanzleramt und Geheimdienstkoordinator im Bundeskanzleramt. Und der wurde befragt zur sogenannten Causa, vorweg.
Vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz ähm Bild am Sonntag und Spiegel äh haben.
Enthüllt, dass zwotausendelf, ich glaube, ihr habt das schon mal angesprochen, ne? Ähm mit dem CIA-Resident.
Gespräch zwischen dem CIA-Repräsentanten und einem dem Abteilungsleiter sechs stattgefunden hat, in dem gesagt wurde, hier der Vorback, der redet zu viel.
Genau, der war in der Sitzung davor da und in der letzten Sitzung war Gunther Heister, der, der eben mit dem CIA-Resident spazieren war, wenn denn die Berichte stimmen, wovon ich äh woran ich keinen Grund habe.
Und da haben natürlich die Abgeordneten gefragt. So, waren sie jetzt mit der CIA spazieren oder äh hatten sie Informationen gegen vorweg, dass der Medienkontakt.
Ähm und dann hat sich der Zeuge aus dem Bundeskanzleramt,
total gemauert, wollte gar nichts sagen, hat zu Wolf auch aus dem Kanzleramt geguckt und gesagt, hilf mir, äh die wollen, dass ich das beantworte, ich will das aber nicht beantworten,
dann haben sie erst gesagt, ja, das ist nicht Untersuchungsgegenstand. Und dann haben wir aber alle Abgeordneten inklusive Sensburg und und dann eben auch für den gesamten Ausschuss und auch für die große Koalition, nicht nur die Opposition, die die Frage gestellt hat.
Aber auch der Ausschuss und der Vorsitzende Sensburg gesagt, nee, das fällt eindeutig unter äh unseren Untersuchungsauftrag, also müssen sie das beantworten.
Wo sich quasi der Ausschuss auch CDU, SPD gegen Bundeskanzleramt gestellt hat, das das passiert da drin schon mal.
Im Endeffekt ging das noch so ein bisschen her dann hat er gesagt das ist nicht von meiner Aussagegenehmigung gedeckt, dann wollten sie wissen, von welchem Teil der Aussage das Genehmigung das nicht gedeckt ist, dann haben sich Paragrafen hin und her an,
Kopf geworfen, da haben sie hat Salzburg wieder gesagt, nö, das sehen wir anders, wenn sie dadrauf bestehen, auf ihre Rechtsauffassung, dann rufen wir jetzt ein Ermittlungsrichter an und der muss das für uns klären.
Und im Endeffekt kam's dann doch dazu, dass heißt die Frage von Ströbele war das beantworten musste, ob er einen Verdacht hatte im Sommer zweitausendelf das vorweg äh sich mit Spiegel äh Kontakte zu Spiegelredaktekteuren hat.
Und nachdem er dann nochmal draußen war mit Kanzleramt, äh Mitarbeiter, Wolf und die beiden sich beraten haben.
Hat er dann nur gesagt, wir hatten kein hinreichend konkreten Verdacht, der straf Ermittlungen ja ermöglichen würde. Was so ein indirektes Eingeständnis ist, aber jede weitere Nachfrage hat dann wurde dann.
Aber da haben wir schon gesehen, wie sich der Ausschuss gegen das Kanzleramt gestellt hat äh und auch recht deutlich. Das passiert schon ab und zu mal,
dann später ähm,
eine Situation, wo irgendwie Konstantin von Nutz gesagt hat, äh so der will jetzt hier eine Sitzungsunterbrechung, um irgendeinen strittigen Punkt äh zu klären,
glaube ich darum ging, dass Pofalla mal aus einer geheimen Akte zitiert hat, was er nicht darf, weil sonst könnte ja der Generalbundesanwalt gegen ihn ermitteln. Ähm ja.
Tatsächlich,
und dann hat Ströbele aus der vertraulichen Akte zitiert, das zu kuntern, hat das Kanzleramt wieder eingehakt, geht nicht, weil verboten und Nutz hat gemeint, ja aber Pofalla darf das oder wie? Ich muss das ja auch klarstellen, wenn da hier,
Sachen in der Öffentlichkeit behauptet, die andere Aktenteile anders sehen und da ging's hin und her, hat nutzen Unterbrechungen, eine Beratungssitzung beantragt und das hat der Ausschussvorsitzende Sensburg dann einfach übergangen, dem hat er nicht stattgegeben.
Also es gibt.
Innerhalb der Abgeordneten in dem äh Ausschuss äh durchaus äh Befindlichkeiten und äh Auseinandersetzungen und wie man hört hinter verschlossenen Türen, noch viel mehr als öffentlich,
die haben ja auch interne Sitzungen, äh die nicht öffentlich sind. Da sollen die, wir hören schon mal ganz schön in die Fetze fliegen und es laut werden.
Aber man kann auch an einem Strang ziehen, wenn es denn der Ausschuss jetzt 'ne Erkenntnis Interesse hat und aus Zeugen was herausgeholt werden soll.
Passiert alles alles möglich.
Wie ist denn dein Gesamteindruck von diesem Ausschuss? Also ähm,
Mich würde noch so interessieren, was was ist jetzt irgendwie? Du hast gesagt, okay Po falla war eines der Unterhaltungshighlights und eine der besseren Sitzungen. Ähm was gab's denn noch so für.
Also mich würde mal interessieren, was was du noch so für Highlights erinnerst. Äh was weiß ich, entweder aus politischer Bedeutung oder aus halt Entertainment-Sicht. Ähm.
Und was so insgesamt dein Gefühl ist, also ähm Anne Roth zitiert ja immer so gerne, dass der der Ausschuss gefährlicher sei als Snowden.
Ähm das hat, glaube ich, Keasen da gesagt, wenn ich das jetzt, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, war das richtig?
Nee, das hat irgendeine anonyme USA-Geheimdienst-Quelle gegenüber der Bild zitiert, das ist in etwa so plausibel äh als dass der BND den Laden gefunden hat.
Okay, ähm.
Ähm also es ist so, jetzt habe ich kurz meinen Faden verloren, also das so.
Gesamteindruck.
Highlight und was ist jetzt so dein Eindruck von, also ist das da was Interessantes? Ist das was Gutes? Ähm,
gehst du dahin aus äh weil du auch denkst, dass da was bei rauskommt oder gehst du dahin, weil du denkst, dass es dokumentiert werden muss, was da
oder gehst du nur dorthin, weil du denkst, da du das dokumentiert werden musst, was da geschieht? Glaubst du, dass dass dieser Ausschuss irgendwie, also wohin wird das führen?
Wieder ganz schön viele Fragen. Äh ich versuche nicht total ausschweifend zu werden, möchte aber trotzdem mal grundsätzlich anfangen, schon also schon allein, dass es den Ausschluss gibt. Ist schon mal geil,
leider gibt's in keinem anderen Land der Erde einen ähnlichen Ausschuss nach dem Snowden-Enthüllungen und das obwohl jedes Land der Erde betroffen ist und äh mindestens fünf, von denen wir schwarz auf weiß wissen, Geheimdienste, wahrscheinlich aber noch viel mehr,
versuchen, die digitale Welt komplett zu überwachen. Insofern ist es schon schon allein, dass er arbeitet und dass er eben äh so Berge an Dokumenten bekommt, auch wenn man sich darüber streiten kann, wie,
viel dem Ausschuss jetzt vorenthalten wird und wie viele geschwärzt werden und welche Operationen der Ausschuss gar nicht erfahren darf und so ist schon mal echt,
ziemlich cool, dass wir so was haben, dass Medien darüber berichten,
glaube, ohne Ausschuss wäre so Operation Eikonal und Glotaik nie bekannt geworden,
wo weder das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium davon wussten noch die G zehn Kommission davon wussten noch erst recht die Öffentlichkeit davon wusste und wie fast alle Zeugen aus dem Bundeskanzleramt sagen die auch nichts davon gewusst.
Also schon allein so einen kleinen Eindruck zu bekommen, äh wie der BND mit äh zusammen mit anderen äh Geheimdiensten arbeitet.
Ähm ist es, finde ich es total spannend. Und es gibt natürlich die großen Erkenntnisse, wie eben die Operationen,
und dann gibt's aber auch jede Menge kleinere Erkenntnisse in jeder einzelnen Sitzung, also ob's jetzt ist, dass der BND.
Bindungsdaten über fünf Ebenen spreche, die Weltraumtheorie, das in Bad Aiblingen keine deutschen Gesetze gelten nie Funktionsträger, Theorie.
Dass unter dass der BND mit Tarnfirmen agiert.
Dass es irgendwie mindestens ein Dutzend Kabelabgriffe gibt, von denen gerade mal zwei oder drei öffentlich behandelt werden sollen,
dass wir so frei über Selektoren reden. Ich mein die vierzigtausend der Selektorenliste die im Bundeskanzleramt liegt und über die gerade gestritt.
Achtunddreißigtausend Selektoren, von denen der BND erkannt hat, dass die äh NSA die benutzt hat, obwohl sie gegen deutsche und europäische Interessen verstoßen,
das wäre ohne diesen Ausschuss so nicht ans Licht gekommen und das ist schon mal eine Erkenntnis,
der Ausschussarbeit habe ich ja wie gesagt auch nun einen Bruchteil haften Eindruck in den öffentlichen Sitzungen, wie gesagt ein Großteil der eigentlichen Arbeit passiert anhand der Dokumente.
Ähm.
Die wir jetzt nicht lesen können, wie die Ausschussmitarbeiter und eben auch in den internen Beratungssitzungen, da wird dann auch Politik gemacht, da berichten dann auch Kanzleramt und Geheimdienstchefs,
öfters mal über was aktuelles, aber auch die öffentlichen Zeugenanhörungen sind durchaus äh öfters mal ziemlich spannend. Also ich gehe da vor allem hin,
Einmal damit angefangen habe äh und weil Netzpolitik jetzt sicherlich nicht mehr damit aufhören,
wird, also wir haben das jetzt einmal angefangen, wir ziehen das jetzt auch durch und es ist ja auch spannend, es ist ja interessant, wir haben ja Leserinnen und Leser, wir haben andere Leute, die das interessiert, die sich nicht,
zwölf Stunden alle zwei Wochen freinehmen können und davon früh bis zu spät drinne sitzen können. Normalerweise arbeiten ja auch, wir haben das Glück, dass wir das als unsere Arbeit bezeichnen können und das machen können.
Aber natürlich würde ich mir das nicht antun, wenn mir das komplett.
Ähm ja, wenn ich da komplett eingehen würde, also manchmal kommt man schon aus dem nicht mehr raus, aber auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise bin ich ja Politik nöt und finde das ja auch interessant,
wieder so die Prozesse von sich gehen und das hautnah mitzuerleben. Und es ist natürlich auch total hilfreich als Journalist,
alles hautnah mitzubekommen, was gerade die äh Gesprächsthemen sind, wo gerade Krise sind, also auch das Zwischenmenschliche, was man ja in dem Text,
immer posten auf Netzpolitik nicht so leicht rausliest wo jetzt wer laut wird und wo es jetzt irgendwie mal kurz zur Sache geht,
und welche Themen dann auch auf dem Flur besprochen werden und wie so die Stimmung ist und so das ist schon alles ziemlich hilfreich, wenn man auch sonst an dem Thema als Journalist dran arbeitet,
ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, welche Themen sind sind jetzt wichtig und welche Richtung sollte man eventuell nochmal nachbohren. Äh und,
kann jetzt nicht meine drei, vier Highlights sagen, ich habe ja schon ein paar Punkte genannt,
die äh rausgekommen sind in dem Ausschuss und die sicherlich noch weitere Folgen haben werden,
der Ausschuss ist ja nicht nur dazu da, herauszufinden A was die machen und B wie der BND und andere Bundesstellen da drin,
involviert sind, sondern eben im dritten Teil im Abschlussbericht auch herauszuarbeiten, wie man sich dagegen schützen kann.
Und das wird ja das wird nochmal spannend was dann in dem Abschlussbericht stehen wird.
Hab ich so 'n bisschen Faden verloren, wir haben ja auch noch zwei Themenfelder, die noch kommen in dem Ausschuss,
neben den Operationen des BND und Kabelabgriffen und Satellitenabgriffen und den Strukturen, was wir jetzt bisher hatten, kommen ja auch noch die Themen, also geheimer.
Also Drohnenmode, die sogenannten extralegalen Tötungen und die Rolle Deutschlands äh und da vor allem äh Ramsteins da drin,
und dann eben auch die Rolle der Internetwirtschaft. Wir haben ja da auch noch die riesen lange Liste mit Hundertzeugen äh von Facebook und Google-Chefs und so äh und hoffentlich irgendwann auch mal AdWords Snowden,
Der Ausschuss hat noch einige an spannenden Themen,
vorsichtig überarbeitet werden wollen, aber immer wieder kloppt dann ein anderes Thema mit Zwischenreihen. Eigentlich wollte man schon längst bei Ramstein sein, dann kam das CD aus Selektoren, jetzt kommt irgendwie die Causa vorbeck.
Das der Verfassungsschutz soll auch noch drankommen,
mal sehen wie viel von seinem Auftrag der Ausschuss überhaupt abarbeiten kann eh spätestens mit Ende der Legislaturperiode die Arbeit dann auch vorbei ist der Abschlussbericht geschrieben werden muss und genau darauf wollte ich vorhin hinaus,
aus den Konsequenzen dann auch ähm gesetzliche Reformen eingeleitet werden. Und da sehe ich tatsächlich eine ganz schöne Gefahr, dass ähm.
Wie so oft äh Frischebrot hat sie ja vor kurzem auf der Tagung hier in Berlin mal wieder gesagt, bei jedem einzelnen Geheimdienst-Skandal in der bundesdeutschen Nacht,
Geschichte sind nach dem Skandal, nach der vermeintlichen Aufklärung äh die Geheimdienste danach personell,
finanziell strukturell gestärkt daraus hervorgegangen. Und das sehe ich als ganz große Gefahr, das haben wir ja gerade eben mit unserer Berichterstattung zum Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz,
bewiesen, ähm dass die nach dem NSU-Skandal jetzt irgendwie Millionen neue Kohle und neue Stellen und neue Befugnisse,
und 'ne Legalisierung von Foulmännern bekommen, aber auch der BND, die der SPD hat ja gerade schon 'nen Vorschlag gemacht für 'ne Reform,
BND-Gesetz und G zehn-Gesetz, was äh in einigen Punkten tatsächlich ganz gute Ideen hat. In anderen Punkten, aber auch auf eine Legalisierung äh von Praktiken hinausläuft, die derzeit einfach ganz klar illegal sind.
Das ist eine große Gefahr, vor allem bei den Mehrheitsverhältnissen mit einer großen Koalition im Deutschen Bundestag,
und da wollen wir natürlich auch unseren Teil dazu beitragen, indem wir eben die Öffentlichkeit darüber informieren, was so passiert, was die Erkenntnisse sind, ehe sie im äh Abschlussbericht stehen oder äh eben nicht nur gefiltert durch,
nur Phoenix-Kamera, dass sich eben Leute auch für das in dem Thema mit engagieren, dort einbringen,
und auch im Parlament und außerhalb äh mit dafür wirken, dass es eben nicht wieder zu einer Ausweitung Legalisierung der fragwürdigen Befugnisse hinauskommt,
endlich mal zu einer strukturellen Form äh von Geheimdiensten und vielleicht einer kompletten,
Evaluation, welche Art von Geheimdiensten bräuchte es überhaupt in einer freiheitlichen äh Demokratie,
und wie wollen wir, dass die aussehen, Stadt jetzt einfach nur zu sagen, ja dann brauchen wir halt nochmal zweihundert Millionen für eine strategische Initiative Technik, wie die BN wie der BND gerade bekommt und eine neue Befugnisse, dass die jetzt in ihrem.
Internet, Glasfaser, am Dezix abschmuscheln, auch nach Viren suchen dürfen, wie es ja gerade vor zwei Wochen beschlossen wurde.
Also das sehe ich ein bisschen als Gefahr, auch wenn die Erkenntnis davor natürlich total spannend ist.
Andre Meister ist Journalist bei Netzpolitik Org, Netzpolitik Org kann mit Spenden unterstützt werden, muss mit Spenden unterstützt werden, weil es
im Prinzip rein spendenfinanziert läuft beziehungsweise Quersubventioniert, wenn's nicht äh an Spenden reicht. Ähm,
Ich bin ein sehr großer Fan von Andres Arbeit und ähm habe mich sehr gefreut
ähm da heute nochmal einen tieferen Einblick rein vermitteln zu können. Andre, vielen, vielen Dank.
Ja, danke, aber da möchte ich nochmal ganz kurz einhaken. Ähm, vielen Dank für die Blumen, aber es geht tatsächlich gar nicht nur um mich, auch wenn ich jetzt irgendwie der Typ bin, der mal den Kopf hinter sich sitzen äh hatte und der irgendwie sich immer in die Sitzungen da setzt jetzt über zwanzig Male, aber ich
demnächst auch wieder eine kleine Auszeit und bin dann weg und auch bisher bei äh anderen Sitzungen äh war nicht immer nur ich, waren auch schon andere Leute aus der Redaktion und das werden auch weiter heute andere Leute aus der Redaktion mitmachen, also ist tatsächlich gesamte Netzpolitik, auch wenn ich irgendwie einmal angefangen hätte und wahrscheinlich ein bisschen öfters als die anderen da war
sind alle, sind ja größeres Team. Du hast ja auch noch einen Account, haha. Einen Blog-Account auf diesem Netzpolitik.
Ja, ja. Ja, den wolltest du ja schon wegnehmen.
Darüber reden wir noch.
So, wir danken und äh freuen uns auf die nächste Woche und beim Camp habt ihr natürlich auch die Gelegenheit, äh Andre und mich zu treffen. Wir trinken beide bevorzugt Pils.
Genau. Das ein oder andere. Kriegt noch ein Bier von dir.